le nez qui
et rougit la voix qui faiblit et le
mouchoir qui se remplit cet homme a tous
les symptômes de la grippe
mais pas de quoi en faire un plat un
virus aujourd'hui pris au sérieux par
les médias mais il fut un temps que
c'est l inverse et ottawa un calva en
guise de remède pour ce monsieur
d'accord pourquoi pas mais le médicament
le plus efficace c'est celui de
l'humoriste pierre dac en 1949 a
désormais le plus possible de vitamines
à demi finale que la carotte contient
énormément d'amis tamina il ya donc lieu
de brandebourg où karol ann lavage
intestinaux mais les aguerris non non
mais hors bessol qu est cependant pas là
on passe à autre chose
à l'époque ce n'est pas le kovy 19 qui
s'est dite en france mais la grippe
italienne en 1949 l'épidémie tu ce qui
n'empêche pas les actualités françaises
de garder un ton désinvolte
les malades ne se comptent plus on
assiste dans tous les domaines à une
sorte de disparition progressive lorsque
la faculté nomme line grippe à puce en
mots lettre non grippés qui pour se
maintenir
voilà your faire feu de tout bois après
l'italienne viendra la grippe asiatique
salaires d'être tout à fait les premiers
symptômes de la grippe
qu'en dit italienne aux asiatiques
suivant les cas puis anglaise mais qu
importe la nationalité du virus se
remettent de 1961 reste comme la
guérison par excellence autre moyen de
combattre la grippe mais celui ci
destinée aux gastronomes le bain de
pieds de mutare avis aux amateurs de
hot-dogs la guérison est au bout du
chapelet de saucisses
la grippe moqué en dessin en sketches
mais aussi en chansons à l'image du duo
jean raymond jean constantin dans
l'émission rue de la gaîté en 1960
est ce que vous avez j'ai attrapé la
grippe c'est pas possible faute et je
vous donne étudiants donnent rien
[Musique]
c'est pas des microbes dans le délai